olá a todos e todas criar começar
agradecendo por aqui para poder
conversar um pouco com vocês sobre
educação e poesia e eu vou falar com
vocês principalmente hoje sobre um
segredo um segredo que ao longo de
alguns minutos a gente vai descobrindo
pouco a pouco e é o segredo das miudezas
o segredo das pequenas asas das coisas
miúdas que a gente pode perceber o nosso
dia a dia que podem desviar a nossa rota
porque no geral a gente está seguindo
uma mesma rota uma mesma rota ea gente
andar pelos mesmos caminhos ea gente
esquece dos desvios que são possíveis e
que podem acontecer a qualquer momento
e se vocês prestarem atenção no que
acontece quando se dá uns viu acontece
uma mudança total do caminho porque se
você vai sempre numa rua e você
simplesmente vira um lado para o outro
tudo o que você vai ver a partir de
então muda então eu vou falar hoje pra
vocês é sobre o que a gente pode ver o
nosso caminho que desvia o nosso caminho
e e esse o que vão ser mil desde as
coisas pequenas coisas que dificilmente
a gente percebe e pra começar falando
das miudezas eu vou contar uma história
pra vocês uma história que fala sobre um
contador de histórias
existia um homem que contava histórias
pessoas e todo mundo da vila disse eu
morava
todo mundo saía dessas conversas com
esse homem muito muito muito marcados
as pessoas iam conversar com esse senhor
contador de histórias
elas ouviram histórias que deixavam elas
muito felizes muito transformada saiam
contando pra todo mundo
nossa eu fui lá eu encontrei o contador
de histórias que ele me contou isso isso
eu não consigo mais esquecer o que ele
me disse que um dia um garotinho ele foi
até o contador de histórias e ele foi
perguntar para o contador de histórias
como o senhor é capaz de contar
histórias para as pessoas
acho que mudam tanto a vida delas o que
o senhor diz pra elas
o quê e aí esse senhor
ele costumava sempre responder às
perguntas de quem quer que seja com uma
história então ele falou que o garotinho
vou te contar uma história
e aí o contador de histórias começou a
dizer
era uma vez um arqueiro
um homem que passou a vida inteira
inteira tentando entender como jogar uma
flecha é um alvo
esse homem passou a vida inteira
tentando entender como fazer com que o
movimento dele conseguisse fazer um ato
preciso e ele passou a vida inteira
treinando ele treinava sozinho à noite
ele ficava jogando flechas entrava no
quarto dele e treinam com os maiores
mestres que ele consegue encontrar pelo
caminho
ele treinou treinou treinou a vida
inteira e coletar mais velho ele já
estava se concentrando bastante sábio na
arte do haiti da faixa ele considerava
que ele era capaz de chegar diante de um
alvo que fosse distante ele conseguiria
jogar uma flash cavassa faixa bem no
meio bem o sempre precisamente
milimetricamente e aí um dia e se a
queiro resolveu participar de encontro
de arqueiros porque ele sempre passou a
vida muito tímido treinando lá em casa
sozinho ele pensou precisa encontrar
mais gente precisa encontrar outras
pessoas e nesse primeiro encontro de
arqueiros em que ele foi
ele chegou e viu uma cena que impactou
muito facilmente porque ele chegou e viu
uma parede a parede que tinha uma altura
pequena mais uma extensão muito longa é
uma parede muito longa com muitos alvos
muitos alvos mas nem muitos alvos
pequenininhos de minutos
alguns grandes um tachinho do outro em
todos esses alvos de uma flecha cravada
bem no meio
muitas flechas cravadas bem no meio
de muitos alvos e aí esse homem se aqui
ficou muito assustado ele falou não é
possível que alguém tenha conseguido
colocar tantas flechas entanto salvos e
é tão parecido jeito como essas flechas
estão gravadas nos alvos que
provavelmente foi uma mesma pessoa que
fez isso
quem será que fez isso e esse arquivo
começa a gritar quem foi que fez isso
quem foi
eu preciso aprender com quem fez isso
como como a pessoa capaz de colocar
tantas faixas em tantos alvos de um
outro garotinho a pele esse garotinho
falou fui eu fui eu que fiz isso e aí
hora que ele for não é possível é
possível é possível que assim você eu
duvido que tenha sido você me conta quem
foi você viu quem foi que fez isso eu
garanto que eu fui eu fui eu
é sério não vai escutar e vai querer não
vou escutar o que você fala quem foi o
garotinho disse o seguinte você não quer
escutar mas eu vou dizer como foi que eu
fiz isso como foi que eu cavei tantas
flechas no meio de tantos alvos
primeiro eu jogo a flecha depois eu
pinto ao redor
primeiro eu jogo a flecha e depois eu
pinto ao redor assim termina a história
do arqueiro um garotinho é a gente volta
a história do contador de histórias com
outro garoto na frente dele imaginemos
um contador de histórias
o garoto na frente dele o contador de
histórias diz
o primeiro é o escuto as pessoas
primeiro eu escuto as pessoas e depois
em torno do que as pessoas me contam eu
pinto uma outra história
primeiro eu escuto depois eu pinto ano
que as pessoas me contam uma outra
história
o que a história de saqueiro desse
contador de histórias nos diz é que a
escuta é muito importante essa história
é uma história que está no livro o alvo
do ilan beeman e uma história que diz
muito sobre essa percepção daquilo que é
meu mundo daquilo que pode mudar nossa
rota
a gente realmente escutar o que está
perto da gente a gente está mais aberto
para aprender com o que está ao nosso
redor
o que está mais perto da gente o convite
eu tenho aqui pra vocês é exatamente
esse que a gente se torne mais aberto
para aprender com que está perto da
gente
eu acabei viajando por vários países pra
escrever um livro sobre educação nível
que eu escrevi com outros amigos chamado
volta ao mundo em três escolas
logo depois de lançar esse livro acabei
indo viajar para outro país eu fui para
a índia na índia onde eu estava andando
por um lugar que tinha muita lama e eu
estava andando com um senhor de 75 anos
que era considerado um mestre na região
e nesse lugar que tinha muita lama eu
estava pisando meu pai estava afundando
e aí esse senhor ele também falou assim
que tal se a gente pegar algumas pedras
e jogar nessa lama na nossa frente a
gente pisa nas pedras para ajudar a
fundar né
e aí lá fui eu procurar as pedras lá na
índia numa região rural da índia lá vou
procurar as pedras e eu fui longe
procurar as pedras longe e esse senhor
ficou lá quando eu voltei algumas pedras
na mão
ele olhou pra mim e falou serviu tanto
de pedras que encontrei por aqui porque
você foi tão longe para procurar o que a
gente está precisando
será que a gente tão longe para procurar
o que também às vezes está perto da
gente muito perto o convite que eu tenho
aqui pra vocês é esse convite para olhar
o que está perto da gente para cuidar do
que está perto da gente porque nesse
mundo com tanto ruído com tanto caos
a gente às vezes
é de totalmente ao ver demandas do mundo
que são tão grandes que são grandezas
tão imensas ea gente esquece de cuidar
do que está mais perto das relações que
estão mais próximas do que a gente mais
tem capacidade de alterar e aí continuam
nessa provocação ea gente escutar mais o
que está perto de agente lançar mais
flechas para perceber o que está próximo
eu vou mostrar pra vocês uma série de
pequenas poesias que eu tenho feito no
cotidiano porque a gente quiser fazer
uma mudança realmente relevante da nossa
rota a gente tem que fazer essa mudança
no cotidiano
a gente tem que fazer essa mudança na
segunda na terça e na quarta e na quinta
e na sexta
nos dias onde a gente está vivendo essa
rotina que alguns chamam de rotina
eu vou mostrar pra vocês algumas dessas
poesias que elas foram reunidas no
fechamento do jornal das miudezas seria
um jornal que noticiasse esses
acontecimentos banais que noticiasse
essa escuta do que é miúdo mas que por
semedo é importantíssimo e parece ser
percebido
messi é apreendido o que eu posso
aprender com uma folha que está no chão
que eu possa aprender com algo que a
princípio até invisível
essa é uma das manchetes do jornal das
miudezas uma folha com rachaduras se
deitar de barriga pra cima com todos os
olhos abertos para descansar seu vazio e
preenchê-lo com o momento exato em que a
noite eo dia se encontram se beijam e se
despedem
a gente pode ver também uma cena como
essa que foi a primeira cena que
originou hoje novas mesas e pensar que a
manchete que essa cena evoca é de que
formigas são flagrados carregando
pedaços diário fury pedaço de árvore
essa cena é uma alegoria
é do trabalho humano a gente vê essa
formiga carregando um pedaço de árvore a
gente vê a gente carrega um pedaço de
árvore
todos os dias e essa cena por exemplo de
uma moeda que é encontrada pedindo
dinheiro na rua e aí resta uma pergunta
vocês até onde vai a ambição até onde
vai a ambição
quando a gente vê essa cena por exemplo
de um lapso que está treinando natação
das miúdas olimpíadas ou essa outra cena
ainda mais emblemática de rachaduras que
se unem contra especulação imobiliária
ou essa outra cena de uma manifestação
repente em que folha de maio e caíram
todas no chão de uma só vez mas a outra
cena de uma bala perdida de uma bala que
decidir na nua pelas ruas de deixar a
roupa abandonado em uma calçada ou essa
outra cena de pedaços de céu que cai no
chão e as pessoas ignoram estes pedaços
de céu pensando que são cacos de vidro
com essa outra cena de latinhas que se
caso e decidir não fazer troca de anéis
mas sim hospedem pelas ruas para que
outros encontrem com essa outra cena e
um passarinho que procure a quem quer
sentar na praça para conversar um
pouquinho essa outra cena de uma pétala
roxa que se casa com a folha verde abre
o coração meu amor é maior que eu com
essa outra cena de um salgadinho que sai
do pacote para tentar a vida como
autônomo isso essas miudezas
elas têm muito a ver com leveza e elas
têm muito a ver com aprendizados densos
por mais que todas essas miudezas que eu
falei aqui elas possam invocar primeiro
uma sensação até de humor mais do que
isso que eu estou propondo é que a gente
aprenda com o que há de mais mil do que
há de mais pequeno na nossa frente
tem uma frase de um pensador indiano que
hoje mora na inglaterra que pra mim é
muito especial
ele disse que no novo paradigma nesse
outro mundo que a gente quer construir o
pequeno ele é celebrado não é o tamanho
que é valorizado mas sim a substância e
sim o que ele representa
o pequeno tem a ver com a decisão do que
a gente vai consumir
quando a gente vai no supermercado nessa
decisão miúda que a gente faz quando a
gente pega um produto e não outro
o pequeno tem a ver com a relação que a
gente tem com as pessoas no nosso prédio
nossa rua a gente fala com elas ou não
o pequeno tem a ver com a relação que a
gente tem com a rua
a gente percebe o caminho que a gente
faz todos os dias ou não a gente percebe
a gente dá tempo para que as coisas
aconteçam
tem uma outra frase também que eu acho
que se conecta intimamente está dizendo
poderoso é aquele que descobre as
insignificâncias do mundo e as nossas
é uma frase manoel de barros e ele até
diz na continuação desse poema que por
essa descoberta pela descoberta de que
poderoso é aquele que percebe a
significância
ele foi chamado de imbecil e ele
continua dizendo sou fraco para elogios
e o ponto é como a gente percebe que
essa percepção
ela é muito importante e poderoso
naquele que descobre ouro mas sim aquele
que percebe as miudezas e aprende com
elas como a gente percebe que as
miudezas das relações
elas estão provocando elas podem
provocar uma educação do sensível uma
educação da percepção e como as miudezas
elas estão pedindo exigindo da gente
um outro tempo para que você consiga
caminhar e perceber esses detalhes para
que você consiga se relacionar com as
pessoas e perceber esses detalhes você
precisa dedicar tempo para isso
não esse tempo acelerado esse tempo
tresloucado esse tempo
esbaforido esse tempo disse o legado sem
fôlego
você precisa dedicar um tempo que
consiga respirar
qual foi a última vez que um de vocês
andam pela rua com calma olhando
realmente os lugares pelos quais estavam
passando
olhando realmente as pessoas como
pessoas e não como estranhos
estrangeiros que merecem estar distantes
qual foi a última vez que isso aconteceu
com a fonte uma vez que a gente se
perguntou o que a gente podia aprender
com o desconhecido
qual foi a última vez e de novo isso é
pequeno mas isso tem muito a ver com as
nossas ações e com os nossos
comportamentos no trabalho no dia a dia
se a gente não consegue perceber essas
pequenas quem dirá as grandezas e qual o
segredo das miudezas o segredo das
miudezas é que elas podem ensinar a
gente até intimidade com a realidade
o paulo freire educador brasileiro muito
importante ele depois de voltar do
exílio porque na época da ditadura ele
passou alguns anos fora do brasil quando
ele voltou
ele disse que é impossível você realiza
um sonho
se você não tiver intimidade com a sua
realidade e quantas vezes a gente tenta
realizar ações sem ter a mínima
intimidade com a nossa realidade mais
próxima né
quando os projetos a gente vê hoje no
mundo em movimento que não tem nenhuma
intimidade com que as pessoas realmente
querem e que estão em movimento porque
foram feitos por pessoas que não estavam
de olhos abertos para perceber essas
miudezas
será que a gente tem coragem de ter
intimidade com a nossa realidade
será que a gente tem coragem de andar
realmente soltando flechas primeiro
antes de sair falando com nossos vícios
as miudezas pedem um tempo mais lento
desde sua última